las chilenas vuelven a salir de forma
masiva en las calles este día
internacional contra la violencia hacia
la mujer con la consigna de unirse
contra el fascismo que representa la
opción de ultraderecha de jose antonio
casi el candidato que se impuso en las
elecciones presidenciales en esta
primera vuelta con carteles como cash tu
presencia no es violenta llamando al
voto contra cash y también con
referencias a uno de los diputados que
causó polémica la semana al cuestionar
el voto de femenino y que hubo de
dimitir del partido de cas por la
polémica originada eso en un día en el
que 16 constituyentes y más de dos veces
220 organizaciones feministas plantean
la propuesta de un nuevo artículo para
la constitución que se está redactando
en este momento en el país una vida
libre de violencia para las mujeres esto
en un país donde el 65 por ciento de las
mujeres afirma haber sufrido algún tipo
de violencia a lo largo de sus vidas
preguntamos algunas de ellas porque
llegaron hoy hasta aquí hoy día estamos
aquí porque necesitamos manifestar que
estamos contra el fascismo que vamos
avanzando una democracia plena y que no
podemos permitir retroceder en todas
nuestras luchas sociales desde nuestra
abuela desde nuestras madres desde
nuestras hijas
espantoso
están todos o cualquier tipo de
comentarios que se refiere a lo que era
vulnerar nuestro derecho a voto
y yo espero y creo y tengo mucha
esperanza que todas las mujeres que
están hoy acá vayan a votar las próximas
elecciones y más que un candidato u otro
que acá no es uno u otro que voten
pensamos nosotras en nosotras en lo que
podemos perder y que yo creo que es muy
grave no al fascismo no al fascismo no
retrocedamos a los años 70 73
porque hemos dado algo creo que hoy en
día tenemos un poco más de derechos
sobre nuestro cuerpo sobre nuestras
opiniones y aún así existe hoy en día la
violencia de género la violencia
obstétrica la violencia de las mujeres
así que creo que hoy estoy acá por mí
por mi huevito por todos los niños por
las mujeres como vemos son cientos las
mujeres que salen a la calle y se unen
contra la amenaza que supone el avance
de la ultraderecha en el país en cuyo
programa está por ejemplo subvención las
diferencias para mujeres casadas frente
aquellas solteras divorciadas u otras
las chilenas se unen salen a la calle
dispuestas a luchar por todos los
avances conseguidos hasta ahora y con el
objetivo de no retroceder en esos
progresos ni un solo paso atrás